Narr: From Apple TV Plus-
What are we looking for again?
That, a Gharial.
Jane: There's only 600 of them left
in the whole world.
Turn back! Turn back!
[screams]
Jane: Graybeard!
Mom!
You know chimpanzees can't swim.
Narr: Based on the mission
of Jane Goodall.
Jane: The animals are in danger.
Every year there are less
and less of them.
We have to help them.
Jane: If everyone worked together,
we could save them.
[chimpanzee sounds]
Only if we understand
will we care.
Only if we care will we help.
Jane Goodall said that.
Mom: I know,
you recite it every morning.
♪♪
Let's go.
Jane: Imagining, let's you
picture something
you've never thought of before.
David: Whoah!
Let’s save some bees.
Ready, Greybeard?
David: Can we put our plan into action?
Jane: Ready if you are.
[screams]
It's cute...
in an ugly kind of way.
♪♪
Narr: Imagine a better world,
and journey, to save one
species at a time.
Yeah!
We’re trying to figure out why
they like to come out at night.
Sounds like quite the mystery.
Have fun saving the world.
Together, huh?
Together.
Run!
♪♪
Jane!
I'm never letting you
out of my sight again.
Jane.
Why does everything we
try to save attack us?
♪♪